a bright flash of light awakens pietro
wilson from his vegetative state he sits
up and brushes the sand off himself
looking around the desolate desert he's
found himself in
how did he get here the last thing he
remembers is uncovering secret orders
from the leaders of the scp foundation
just before they declared war on
humanity unfortunately the most
important parts of the files had been
redacted now he's on a mission to
finally discover why the scp foundation
is trying to kill every last human on
the planet but there is something else
he has to deal with first what happened
pietro says out loud as he looks at his
vitals in the heads-up display of
scp-5000
he is still contained within the
exclusionary suit that makes him
undetectable to human senses
he checks the date and gasps in surprise
three months i've been passed out for
three months
he stands up and looks across the barren
landscape the screen inside the suit
indicates that he has traversed half of
the country since he left site 19 three
months ago
pietro looked down at one of his hands
he is holding a leather briefcase where
did that come from he wonders pietro has
no idea what is inside the briefcase but
he knows it definitely isn't round he
tries to let go his fingers won't open
he uses his other hand to try and pry
the briefcase away from himself but his
hand only clasps to it harder then a
wave of calm washes over him something
inside his head speaks to him but it's
not a voice more like a feeling it is a
sense of purpose and pietro's new
mission in life is to deliver this
briefcase to scp-579
nothing else is as important pietro
wilson takes a deep breath and embraces
his new purpose in life
he still wants to uncover the reason
that the scp foundation is trying to
wipe out humanity but this will have to
wait until he delivers the briefcase to
scp-579
pietro doesn't know exactly where 579 is
located but he can feel a pull in a
certain direction so he begins to walk
pietro brings up the information stored
in the scp-5000 suit from the
foundations database he finds that all
information about what scp-579 is has
been expunged from the record the only
useful information in the file is that
the ketter level scp is located at site
62c
at least pietro has a destination to aim
for he travels for days without seeing a
living soul but he does pass thousands
of corpses he tries to ignore them but
one stands out to him inside a house as
he searches for supplies
it's the body of a recently deceased boy
he couldn't have been more than eight
years old
he was so young
pietro thinks
he bends over to scoop up the body and
bury it outside
as his hand touches the body the boy's
skin begins to move it is as if hundreds
of tiny creatures are scurrying just
under the skin
then from out of every orifice comes
hundreds of little pale worms
each with the face of the boy
they're all cackling as they crawl out
of the boy's body and into a drain a few
feet away
pietro jumps back and runs this is the
last person i try to bury he thinks
pietro pushes forward
the hundreds of little laughing worms
haunting his thoughts until he puts a
significant distance between himself and
the little boy's body
pietro continues to walk towards the
direction of site 62c he passes more
corpses but decides to stay clear of
them
although the suit makes it so pietro
doesn't need to rest he can only go so
fast
he enters a small abandoned town that
looks like something out of an old
western movie a tumbleweed blows across
the dirt road pietro sits on the wooden
step of the local saloon and takes a
break he looks down at the briefcase in
his hand he hasn't had the urge to open
it only to deliver it to scp-579
pietro puts the briefcase on his lap he
stares at it and slides his hands along
the leather stops with his thumb on the
latch and pushes the locks snap open
pietro opens the briefcase a bright
light beams out and he passes out
when pietro comes to again he is miles
closer to site 62c
there is a warm feeling enveloping his
body he looks down at the briefcase
which is now closed
wow this thing is like my own personal
skip button
pietro thinks
he holds up the briefcase unlatches the
locks sees the bright light and passes
out again he awakes once again miles
away from his last position
so it wasn't just a one-off effect
pietro continues walking across the
country switching between using his own
legs and whatever magic is contained
within the briefcase he is making faster
progress now
as he walks through a dense deciduous
forest he comes across a pack of wolves
eating the remains of an scp agent
pietro is undetectable to the wolves
thanks to the scp-5000 suit
and he makes his way over to the pack
quietly grabbing a laptop laying on the
ground next to the agent's body pietro
takes the laptop and goes away deeper
into the forest before stopping to boot
up the computer
he has not forgotten about the horrors
the scp foundation has released and he
needs to know how the world has been
doing over the last few months
what he finds is
not good the scp foundation has
triggered the eruption of yellowstone
destroying scp-2000 which unknown to
pietro contained the failsafe for
rebuilding human society in the event of
a world-ending scenario which this was
starting to look more and more like it
was only a matter of time now before the
soot and ash thrown up by the eruption
blocks out the sun in much of what is
left of the united states
the foundation has also found a way to
get
scp-2241 to do their dirty work at
refugee camps the young brown-haired boy
is most likely being manipulated by the
foundation under the pretense that they
are only doing what is best for their
child he has caused whole groups of
refugees to turn on each other leading
to a massacre the last entry says that
the young boy is being sent to the
global occult coalition hold out in
genzir to help destroy some of the last
threats to the scp foundation a series
of other scps have been dispatched by
the foundation around the world to
continue the destruction of humanity
they even managed to use temporal
anomalies to make it christmas time
everywhere around the world so scp-4666
the brutal yuletide creature that stalks
the homes of children is free to cause
chaos
pietro had seen enough
he slams the laptop shut throws it
against the trunk of a tree and opens
the briefcase again he awakes standing
feet away from a group of global occult
coalition soldiers who are sitting
around a campfire maybe they know why
the scp foundation is trying to end the
world he thinks he decides that it is
too risky to show himself to the
soldiers but take some solace in sitting
around the campfire with other living
humans
the soldiers are sharing stories about
what is happening one catches the
attention of pietro wilson it is strange
but also may hold a clue as to why the
scp foundation is trying to wipe out
humanity one of the soldiers recounts an
event that he witnessed before leaving
the global occult coalition's
headquarters at genzir
they had just captured an scp soldier
trying to break into the base
the infiltrator's name was samuel ross
he had been strapped into an
interrogation chair and questioned the
interviewers were not getting anywhere
until ross was threatened with torture
to which he responded do what you want
once you realize you're not supposed to
feel pain there's nothing to be afraid
of anymore
pietro sits up straight and starts to
listen more intently
he remembers stumbling across scp
soldiers on his way to site 19 that
exhibited the same no pain mentality
that this samuel ross seems to have
after that odd statement by samuel ross
there was the sound of wind it started
slow at first then ramped up until it
was howling like a hurricane that's when
the screaming started the screams became
louder and climbed to a higher pitch
then the room went dead silent the last
thing that samuel ross said was
look what you've done to yourselves i
told you you wouldn't like it didn't you
that's why you hear your voice
but you wanted to know so badly i really
liked you guys so i was trying to be
nice
we're so kind to you you know
we fight in the light
so you can die in the dark
disgusting
pietro sits back on his haunches and
rocks back and forth he has an ominous
feeling that there is a connection
between the missing pain of the scp
soldiers
and the reason why the foundation
declared war on humanity the soldier who
told the story of samuel ross stands up
after that interview is when the
destruction of genzir started from the
inside it is why the global occult
coalition is no more god help us all the
soldier finished with a story turns from
the others and starts to walk away as
the soldier makes his way towards the
woods pietro can just barely make out
that he's taken his pistol from his
holster before he disappears into the
darkness the world truly has gone mad
pietro opens the briefcase and blacks
out pietro sluggishly continues his walk
he's moving down a rocky path in the
middle of the forest and his will to
keep going is slowly being drained
the only reason he has not sat down and
given up is because of the driving urge
to get the briefcase to 579
he wants so badly to concentrate and
discover the reason that the foundation
released the scps on humanity but the
need to reach 579 won't let him focus on
anything else
he's noticed though that every time he
opens the briefcase to skip ahead he
makes less and less progress the warm
feeling of the first few transports has
been replaced by a nauseated headache
every time he comes out of the trance
pietro exits the forest into an open
field the wind blows across the high
grass looking like green waves and
standing scattered throughout the field
are statues as pietro approaches he sees
that they are statues of mobile task
force foundation soldiers
he slowly walks closer to the white
marble statues he reaches the first one
and looks at the face of the frozen
soldier
his eyes have been scooped out
all that remains are black empty sockets
the arms of the soldier have been carved
into blades like a praying mantis he
walks past the first statue and proceeds
to the next one where he hears something
move in the grass behind him
he spins around to look at the statue he
could have sworn it was in a slightly
different position
no that's crazy
pietro thinks
he continues to the next statue it is
another carving of an mtf soldier
no eyes blades for arms
this is really creepy pietro says aloud
he proceeds through the field he walks
up a slight hill and turns around to
look at the field of statues
what he sees is terrifying the statues
have all moved and are now in different
positions
it appears as if they were slashing
through the area looking for something
or someone
pietro continues over the hill and comes
upon a group of refugees
they are picking through the field
looking for futi a fog begins to move in
it is being swept across the meadow by
the wind pietro watches from a distance
as the fog envelops the small group
suddenly there is screaming and the
sound of blades going through flesh
the screams cease almost immediately
pietro runs down the hill to where the
refugees were the fog lifts
the group of people have been cut to
pieces
standing in the middle of the carnage is
one of the mtf soldiers statues blood
dripping from its blade arms
pietro knows what to do
he runs
after a few miles pietro slows to catch
his breath those statues must have been
created by the foundation he thinks it's
as if they are frozen in place
but as soon as you take your eyes off
them they can move with killer
speed even in the suit my eyesight can
stop them but they can't see me
they must know i'm there though since
they can't move pietro wilson opens the
briefcase once again for what he didn't
know would be the last time when he
comes to this time he is near site 62c
he can feel himself being pulled
stronger than ever in the direction of
his destination he walks down a deserted
road past the husks of burnt vehicles
and at the end is the gate to site 62c
there are no guards or security of any
kind it looks like the site has been
abandoned for a long time and the gate
is wide open beckoning pietro wilson
into site-62c where
scp-579 waits
pietro wilson enters the dark hallway he
somehow knows leads down into the crypt
of site-62c
the walls drip with what he hopes is
water from leaking pipes but it has a
metallic smell
and is much too red to actually be water
he begins to feel nauseous it gets
harder to breathe even the scp-5000 suit
can't keep him calm
he turns and runs back up the stairs out
of sight 62c pietro begins to sob
uncontrollably
as the memories of everything that has
happened over the past several months
suffocates his will to go on
then as if an invisible force that
refuses to let him go takes control
pietro feels as if a gun has been shoved
into the small of his back he is being
sent back into site-62c whether he wants
to go or not
he is unsure if what is forcing him back
into the base is inside the briefcase
his own uncontrollable urge to know what
is going on or
scp-579 itself but he cannot stop
himself from re-entering the doorway and
proceeding into site-62c
he doesn't know what scp-579 looks like
but pietro has a sinister feeling that
it is watching him he reaches the bottom
of the stairway and proceeds down a dark
hallway the power went out a long time
ago and the only light in the depths of
site-62c is the dim glow coming from the
helmet of the scp 5000 suit pietro
notices long gashes along the concrete
walls as if someone took a giant knife
and dragged it from one end of the
hallway to the other there is something
at the end of the corridor that pietro
can't make out as he gets closer the
lights on the scp-5000 suit begin to
flicker the thing at the end of the
hallway seems to move slightly each time
the lights on the suit dim
the lights on the suit go out completely
and the entire hallway is plunged into
darkness
only for a second though and when the
lights come back on a statue of an mtf
soldier looms over pietro
its eyes are empty sockets its lips are
turned up in a snarl the arms have been
filed into blades
no
pietro screams he dodges around the
statue the moment it is out of his sight
he hears the sound of blades on concrete
as the statue of the soldier comes to
life and begins slashing its way down
the hallway it cannot see pietro
but it knows he is there it slashes all
around trying to connect with whoever is
there with it
pietro runs to the end of the hallway
and reaches the door he presses against
the heavy metal door to open straining
against its weight all while the blind
statue is still slashing coming closer
and closer
the door is almost open but then pietro
feels a blade lacerate the back of the
suit cutting deeply into the skin of his
back missing his spinal cord by
millimeters
another blade enters through the back of
his shoulder piercing straight through
he somehow pulls himself through the
crack doorway and kicks the metal door
shut behind him
he can hear the banging and scraping of
blades outside the metal door the
creature has not given up and is trying
to break in pietro turns around to see
he is in an observation chamber full of
instruments and screens
blood runs down his back from the wounds
inflicted by the statue he walks slowly
over to the window on the desk in front
of him is a file labeled scp-579
he looks through the observation glass
and down into the chamber below it is
too dark to make anything out but pietro
can feel that
scp-579 is down there looking up at him
pietro looks to his left and sees a hole
in the floor he walks over and looks
down and leads right into the
containment chamber of 579. let's get
this over with pietro says out loud he
holds the briefcase over the hole and
tries to open his hand his finger won't
budge
scp-579 wants him to hand deliver the
briefcase pietro wilson takes a deep
breath closes his eyes and steps into
the opening of the hole he falls in the
moments before he lands in
scp-579's containment chamber something
comes to him he realizes that he isn't
going to be a hero he isn't going to
figure out why the scp foundation is
trying to wipe out humanity and he isn't
going to survive
he lands hard on the ground below it is
completely dark except for a shadow that
moves in the corner of the containment
chamber pietro wilson creates one last
log if anyone ever reads this
please
please figure out why
explain it to me
someone
anyone
i don't get it
i just don't get it
scp-579
steps into the glow that the scp-5000
suit is giving off
petra wilson looks up at it
oh
so that's how it is
he says before
scp-5000 creates its final log
live signs
lost
vital signs
lost
scp-5000 appeared in a flash of light in
the containment chamber of
scp-579 located in site-62c
the researchers monitoring scp-579 had
no idea where the suit came from or why
it contained the body of pietro wilson a
foundation employee who is assigned to
site 0-6 and is very much alive
wilson appears to have no knowledge of
scp-5000 or memories of the events
logged in scp-5000 databanks although
the suit is believed to have been
capable at one point of a number of
anomalous functions and abilities the
damage it has sustained has rendered it
inoperable except for the storage of
data files which now have been archived
and stored on secure foundation servers
still have questions about scp-5000 and
what really happened well we've got a
surprise for you go watch
scp-5000 the story explained available
right now to get the story behind the
story of pietro wilson and the scp
foundation's plan to destroy the world